in piazza chi si iscrive spa vi fa bene
a tutti ragazzi venuti a questo video
sono falli j
allora ragazzi non so se vi ricordate
l'anno scorso feci mi feci 20 cose che
non puoi fare se non hai vent'anni
quest'anno scoperto che esiste anche 29
cose di cui devi smettere di
preoccuparti se hai vent'anni io che ho
vende o 21 però in realtà ne dimostro 15
però facciamo una media viene fuori 20
leggiamoli insieme argomentiamo un po
questa minchiata o no tenerti al passo
con le mani e dei giovani certo tua
sorella diciottenne io ho una sorella
diciottenne e tua sorella diciottenne
conosce la nuova musica le nuove droghe
il nuovo le nuove droghe ma riuscirebbe
a fare se a fare sesso con il suo
ragazzi che cosa cazzo sto leggendo ma
riuscirebbe a fare sesso con il suo
fidanzato senza svegliare la sua
coinquilina che dorme con lei nella
stessa stanza
no vabbè primi lei è più sfigata lite
per definizione di che cosa cazzo appena
eletto passava al prossimo punto con
ricky è che ha scritto questo articolo
voglio sapere anzi che l'ha scritto va
bene così numero 3 devi smetterla di
chiederti se hai raggiunto all'età
giusta gli obiettivi tv6 prefissa quando
avevo 16 anni quando avevo 16 anni
credevo che a vent'anni avrei pubblicato
un libro a 23 sarei andata a vivere con
il mio fidanzato è ovviamente non è
successo non devi preoccuparti di
trovare un fidanzato se sei single non
devi per forza riempire quello che
preferisci come uno spazio negativo o un
vuoto nella tua vita devi aggiungere
qualcuno possibilmente fantastico alla
tua esistenza già abbastanza piena e
soddisfacente va bene a questa anche
abbastanza ovvia noi single non è gay
che gli frega un cazzo di trovare una
ragazza a noi single hanno i single
canoa noi single single non devi
preoccuparti di fidanzarti se stai
uscendo con qualcuno uscire come un
sacco di ragazze divertente una volta
il suo no io sono un maschio porca
[ __ ] devo per forza avere le tette
perché non potete scrivere gli articoli
come unisex porca eva ok un ragazzo così
saresti disposta a sposarlo domani ma
non lo farai quindi rilassati questo
caso di articolo incita la free endzone
essere più magra mangia un grisbì mangia
tutti i crismi
io mangio anche il frigo però la
situazione non cambia est i ragazzi di
minchia non ti devi preoccupare di
dimenticarti la matematica è sola la
soluzione cielo perfetta io la
matematica non l'ho mai saputa quindi
siamo a posto
non devi preoccuparti di andare a letto
con troppi ragazzi cosa mi sto facendo
della mia vita pavè ragazzi passiamo a
quello dopo visto che ci sono un
miliardo di articoli così diamo
un'occhiata anche a questo 16 cose che
devi fare a vent'anni se hai una
relazione smettila di giocare con lui io
non so perché ma dopo questo articolo
divento gay sei una relazione con
qualcuno è molto probabile che ti
piaccia minchia veramente giacca chi ha
scritto statico dovrebbe essere sherlock
holmes dove c'è scritto chi ha scritto
l'articolo acquista un vero letto dove
cazzo hai dormito fino adesso per terra
che stavano letto disegnato coi pastelli
per terra e dormito lì dove cazzo
dormito fi del gran sasso ma dio sante
fai un sacco di sesso davvero un sacco
ma pop ma nel caso di incita al sesso
sto articolo costruisci una vita insieme
a lui ma prima non hai detto che bisogna
fare donarli tutti i sedici lezioni di
vita che devi imparare prima dei 20 anni
fino a quando non diventi ricca e famosa
ai prodotti di make up a meno di 3 euro
a faccia ragazzo già risolto quindi io
domani vado da sephora e mi dipingo
anche il culo saper cucinare almeno tre
cose senza errori nella vita ti serve
l'unica [ __ ] cosa che fino ad ora
condivido è vero ragazzi se andate a
vivere da soli o da sole ma adesso mi
riferisco ai maschi perché porco 2
un'ora che parlano le femmine se andate
a vivere da soli dovreste imparare a
cucinare perché io so fare solo ed
esclusivamente la pasta e ce n'è voluto
di tempo perché prima mango quella per
togliere del sangue dal tessuto mettilo
sotto l'acqua fredda
ricapitolando ragazzi abbiamo trovato
articoli che incitano al sesso articoli
che incitano alla franzoni articoli che
incitano all'omicidio per togliere al
cazzo vuol dire per togliere il sangue
spiega mi 12 armi che bossi
non meritano il tuo tempo ariete cinque
cose che devi fare per vivere al massimo
i tuoi 20 anni per chi in questo momento
e ariete sta guardando questo video
aspetta è che morì diamo forse vent'anni
ti sembrano tanti ma in realtà hai
davanti la vita intera però ricordati
quando giochi a pokemon gogh stai fuori
guarda un attimo camion che passa perché
sennò con gas non prenderti troppo sul
serio e lascia sempre un po di spazio
alla passione alle cose che più leggere
che sogni e alle cose che più leggere
che sogni alle cose che più le aspetta
che sta frase quella devo capire quindi
devo rileggere la più volte alle cose
che più leggere che sogni e che provi a
fare tu e non ho capito ragazzi non ho
capito un cazzo di questa frase ultima
che ho appena letto s'è capito qualcosa
fatemelo sapere
eccola qua cielo ragazzi fermi 15 cose
che dovresti fare se sei single a
vent'anni single prego iddio di non
essere quella destra non ti accontenti
di uomini di merda amici papà papà non
c'è niente da guadagnare circondandosi
di persone tossiche per caso stai dando
del tossico a mio padre numero 13
investi su te stesso bene un po
difficile se guidi tu come cazzo francia
mentre va la macchina devi aprirà
portiere sfilarti po difficile però ci
prova cosa cazzo ho appena letto
masturbati bonjour finesse madame de sto
cazzo va bè ragazzi ho letto un po di
cose forse un po troppo e anzi spero che
queste cose siano state utili
soprattutto alle persone single perché
minchiate che leggo mi fanno troppo
scassare 15 ho dovuto fare un video
scusatemi entra ghazi spero che vi sia
piaciuto che con crupi l'episodio di
oggi cosa ito ragazzi servito il rifiuto
sotto un commento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come descrizione
100 arresti di schettini ci rivediamo
nel prossimo vito belle ragazze